the difference between a 5 000 a month  only fans girl and a 200 000 a month  like is it a content strategy is it a  look i feel like it's not just a look i  feel like it's like a viral hook and  story with skye we like played into the  fact that she worked at target and so we  did this tick tock outside of a target  where we like made it seem like she was  like bringing out our stuff that we  bought to our car and it like it really  works and also target's like a super  relatable place for a guy who feels like  he can meet a hot girl right maybe at  target so she like took a bunch of  photos in her target uniform and stuff  so you're not only selling a look you're  selling a story behind it yeah in the  best case yeah but then i mean there are  some girls who like have no personality  but have like the biggest [ __ ] ass  you've ever seen in your life it's a  combination if you could be personality  look and having like a narrative that's  the best case